[Musique]
une vague de froid qui persiste le
département étaient sous vigilance tout
au long de la semaine des fortes chutes
de neige sont tombés dans la nuit du
mardi 9 février entraînant une fermeture
des établissements et transports
scolaires le mercredi
autre phénomène naturel la crue de la
seine plusieurs communes ont été
touchées par la montée du fleuve une
surveillance devenue récurrente en hiver
à l'image des bateliers du bras de marly
préparer pour les éventuels débordements
depuis lundi les étudiants de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peuvent
retourner en cours en présentiel pour la
promotion de droits
ce sont environ 300 élèves présents
contre 3000 habituellement 33 pour cent
des étudiantes souffrent de précarité
menstruel dans les universités
françaises
l'association poèmes de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines a
décidé d'agir en organisant des
distributions gratuites de protection
hygiénique la région ile-de-france va
quant à elle installer des distributeurs
de protection menstruel les 465 lycées
publics devraient en être équipés
bientôt le bois de l'étang au coeur des
tensions à la verrière
contrairement à son projet initial de
rénovation du quartier le maire nicolas
d'un ville souhaite vous désormais une
démolition de 214 à 264 logements
un dossier qui suscite certaines
oppositions au sein du conseil municipal
et parmi les habitants
[Musique]